[Music]
we talked with the lovely Megan Markel
two years ago and asked her who her
ultimate talent crush was her girl crush
Kerry Washington she's amazing that's
amazing she's so beautiful and so
talented and I'm so happy for her cuz
marriage rocks so welcome to the club
girl you gonna tune in to the Royal
Wedding I remember when my mom woke me
up as a baby girl to watch Princess
Diana get married so I probably will
tune in while Carrie made that
confession on the scandal finale red
carpet millions were tuning in to
witness her do that white jacket strut
one last time after seven seasons we saw
Olivia Fitz officially back together
while lives ex Jake
landed in prison I thought everybody got
got the ending that was appropriate for
their character the night shocker
ladee ater attorney general murdered by
the VP and in the final scene a fast
board moment two little girls the one on
the right is show creator Shonda Rhimes
a real-life daughter gazing at what
could be President Pope
why is Olivia Pope's portrait hanging in
the National Portrait Gallery why do you
think that is in the actual screenplay
for the episode it says what it's not
clear whether it's because she's the
president or a first lady and it was a
gladiator goodbye on Kimmel where rhymes
lips remain sealed on the Pope portrait
do you know I know
[Music]
[Applause]